voici la plus grande serre au monde
construite sur un toit des plants de
légumes qui poussent sur 160 3000 pieds
carrés l'équivalent de trois terrains de
football
nous sommes dans l'arrondissement saint
laurent dans l'ouest de montréal au
dessus de l'ancien centre de
distribution de cyrus nécessaire qui
pose sa disparité de tomates et 3 verte
et d'aubergines c'est vraiment fou a
commencé productif alors on vient de
commencer accueillir et on s'attend
qu'il retrait de 25 mille unités de
tomates et d'aubergines par semaine
[Musique]
l'avantagé principal c'est vraiment
l'énergie dans cette serre là on reçoit
à près de la moitié de l'énergie de
chauffage seul immeuble et de la ville
parce que c'est plus chaud en ville et
sur un poids chaufferont sainte foy qui
choquera assez beaucoup plus chaud alors
on a besoin de la moitié de l'énergie de
chauffage pour chauffer notre ère
c'est la quatrième sert des fermes l'ufa
dans la région montréal l'entreprise qui
produit et vend des aliments du québec
depuis 2011 a le vent dans les voiles
elle distribue maintenant 25000 panier
chaque semaine à ses clients membres en
à double id du volume un peu du jour au
lendemain à cause de la pandémie
si vous vous mettez devant l'ascenseur
et lors de l'accueil at t on dirait que
c'est cette haine c'est une boîte
magique qui fait créer des légumes
l'arrivée du coronavirus a poussé les
québécois à manger local pour encourager
les commerçants d'ici au panier bluche
site de référence créé par québec pour
les aider on avance quand mais un
québécois sur quatre a acheté plus de
produits locaux qu'avant aujourd'hui on
a près de 1500 2000 produits sur notre
marché on a près de 250 partenaires qui
complémentent un petit peu notre offre à
la plupart des légumes frais ça reste
toujours une les nôtres dans l'ancien
mais on a du pain en adulé on à du
fromage de la viande s'est tout dé des
familles québécoises qui partage un peu
notre vision la maison du raviolis à
montréal est un des partenaires de l'ufa
ici on fabrique des pâtes fraîches
depuis 1976
les clients sont particulièrement
nombreux depuis quelques mois
première l'afld l'effet de la corvée du
feq et jean
alizée commencé beaucoup plus important
d'acheter local alors c'est pour ça
qu'ils vont vers ces tendances là étant
grandissante
les gens aujourd'hui veulent avoir un
petit peu un contact humain avec les
gens sont son veulent revenir un peu
qu'est ce que c'était et kylie qui à
rentrer à l'intérieur sont très contents
puis ils nous auraient travaillé la
ferme du rang 4 dans lanaudière élèves
abba et transforme des ports l'origine
de la viande est facilement retrace à
bhl et les opérations ici sont peu
mécanisée
l'entreprise a pratiquement doublé ses
ventes depuis mars
elle fournit aujourd'hui quelque 3500 kg
de viande par semaine à l'ufa et la
demande de plusieurs autres de ses
clients comme les supermarchés métro a
aussi augmenté avec la limite violent à
présent courage et locales moi c'est
venu toucher directement mais marché nos
clients général cherche un produit pour
s'identifier
toutes mes clients en fait on grossit
dans cette crise là parce que le monde
se déplaçait plus pour aller chercher
les produits locaux
si j'ai un souci la demande pour les
produits locaux semblent en croissance
voici le jardin sur le toit du
supermarché de la famille du chemin dans
l'arrondissement saint-laurent
un projet unique en amérique du nord qui
existe depuis quatre ans la trentaine de
variétés de légumes cultivés ici se
retrouve dans ce petit kiosque juste en
bas ils représentent 5% des ventes des
produits bio du supermarché ce camp même
du long terme au niveau de la
rentabilité
en fait parce qu'on y 3 en fait parce
que c'est un beau projet daniel du
chemin n'a aucune statistique pour le
prouver mais une bonne impression qu ici
aussi ses produits québécois au plus que
jamais la cote
les fournisseurs locaux sont nombreux
sur les tablettes et l'intérêt pour ce
qui pousse sur le toit est énorme
les gens sont vraiment fiers on entend
parler souvent d'un quartier lasser les
produits du toit ça arrive qu'un la
terreur au printemps combien les radis
qui sortent au printemps le plus tôt que
les produits arriveront sans vraiment un
engouement
surtout cette année avec tout ce qui
s'est passé les gens achètent de plus en
plus locaux l'appui rien de plus de
quelqu'un que des produits sur la toile
il admet comme bien d'autres que les
aliments bio locaux peuvent être un peu
plus cher le prix à payer pour bien
manger tout en encourageant l'économie
du québec
cet intérêt grandissant des derniers
mois continuera-t-il encore longtemps
bien des producteurs d'ici pense que oui
[Musique]